crois-tu en l'existence d'autres
dimensions Nina je n'y crois pas
j'y suis déjà allé moi-même
Nina
Hagen salut tu penses que tu
es la seule star allemande depuis que nous avons
entendu parler de Marlene Dietrich
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et un je ne suis pas allemand je suis juif et
point deux je ne suis pas allemand je suis allemand de l'est
et euh 0.3 je ne suis pas allemand de l'est je suis
Nina Hagen et je suis ce que je suis et je serai toujours
ce que  Je ne suis pas allemand ni
français ni américain
je suis
préféreriez-vous être la nouvelle Janice
Joplin puisque vous euh avez mis une de ses chansons
sur votre dernier album la chanson que je chantais
déjà quand j'avais 12 ans parce que
je suis un hippie du  Les années 60, vous savez, j'ai
déjà 35 ans et c'est l'une
des chansons que j'ai toujours chantées depuis que j'ai commencé à
chanter Je chante Janice Joplin James Brown
Tina Turner vous savez c'est comme ça que j'ai
grandi en chantant toutes les chansons de My Heroes
et c'est mon héros  et je ne veux pas être
comme elle je veux juste être comme moi
personnellement Nina utilise sur ton dernier album
do y  ous pensez que la perestroïka a besoin de votre
soutien en fait je peux vous dire que je suis
invitée par Raisa gorbachova pour une grande
fête à Moscou le 11 mars et
non pas le 11 c'est mon anniversaire le
8 mars c'est la
journée internationale de la femme et moi  Je suis censé
donner un concert là-bas non seulement un mais
environ cinq et nous allons aussi jouer à
Leningrad et Odessa et donc ça va
être ma première fois en Union soviétique et
je suppose que s'ils me veulent ils ont besoin de moi
Nina pensez-vous que  les gens vont
continuer à fuir l'Allemagne de l'Est ou
qu'un changement politique se produira bien
je pense que si ça continue comme ça a toujours l'
habitude d'aller comme ça les gens veulent
sortir pas seulement depuis hier depuis
toujours je pense que ça va être vide
et personne  va être là plus
et ça va être comme une zone libre de la
nature
et ils vont avoir de nouveaux types de
lézards ça va être comme une
zone naturelle comme c'est un parc ou quelque chose
où nous pouvons tous aller passer des vacances
Qu'est ce qui était  ces taleman pionniers euh auxquels vous
appartenez quand vous étiez en Allemagne de l'Est,
nous avions le nom de Taylor man pione parce que
Tilman était en fait un bon gars, il s'est battu
contre les fascistes fascistes pendant la guerre
et nous étions donc comme les anges gardiens
à New York nous étions le  équipe et pionnier
à Berlin-Est, nous avions aidé des personnes âgées que
vous connaissiez à leur apporter de la nourriture ou à
descendre leurs ordures et des choses comme ça, nous sommes
comme des pionniers à quoi vouliez-vous
ressembler quand vous étiez enfant je voulais
devenir vendeur de glaces  femme je
veux avoir un magasin et vendre des glaces
comment voulais-je ressembler à ma mère je
pense maintenant où avez-vous obtenu le son des
vaisseaux spatiaux Landing UFO que vous utilisez sur
votre disque dans une chanson intitulée la vie
de très bons amis de  le
mien qui vient de l'avoir mis sur une
cassette parce que quand j'ai vu mon OVNI j'étais
comme paralysé je ne pouvais pas bouger je
ne pouvais même pas appeler mes amis parce que
schweige a ensuite pris un magnétophone
et les a regardés ou quelque chose ou une caméra
à  connectez-les  J'étais comme ça
pendant deux heures c'était super tu
crois en l'existence d'autres
dimensions Nina je n'y crois pas
j'y suis déjà allé moi même qu'une
dernière question Miss Hogan tu t'es déjà
quitté pendant que tu étais sur cette
planète
je  pense que tu as déjà ressenti la dépression
présente Je fais toujours chaque
minute
c'est comme si
ça me frappait juste es-tu un prophète Nina Je
pense maintenant que changerais-tu en
toi si tu avais le Magic Touch
eh bien rien je serais juste  très occupé
et travaille 24 heures sur 24 sur l'art
nous l'avons adoré alors Nina qu'est-ce que tu
te dis quand tu me vois dans le
miroir le matin rien ne
me brosse les dents